It's April.
It's day one of 30 of the new 30 days to stop
the spread, the new shutdown of the U.S. and
states that are participating. I'll update
you daily on the numbers for the time being.
Official Corona virus, death toll globaly
as of this morning, eight hundred seventy
six thousand. The official death toll, forty
three thousand five thirty three. In the U.S.,
we officially have over one hundred and eighty
eight thousand cases and four thousand fifty
nine deaths. The latest modeling from I H
M E expects the U.S. death toll to be ninety
three thousand seven hundred sixty five. That's
updated daily based on actual case data. It
will be a difficult month. We knew they would
do it. And now it's starting the next war
or battle lines on the disinformation propaganda
that is being spread from the fact lists.
Trump is right is to claim that the corona
virus death toll is fake. Now, what's amazing,
or maybe not, is that there is a real story
about an inaccurate corona virus death toll.
But the story is that the real death toll
is probably higher than the official count,
not lower. But I'll get to that in a second.
Let's go through. First, what's being said
so that we all understand this. First, we
had no cases. And because we weren't testing,
Donald Trump bragged we continue to have few
cases and other countries are starting to
have more cases. Of course, eventually testing
started to ramp up. And the case numbers started
to go up and they started to tell us, well,
our case numbers are going to increase artificially
quickly because we are doing so much testing.
It's still not a reason to be alarmed. Now,
that's partially true, but the case number,
which is now closing and closing in on 200000
thousand cases in the U.S., it still understates
the real number of cases because not everybody
is getting tested. But one thing you can't
fake is the death toll, right, which is now
around 4000, the deaths or deaths, no matter
how much you are testing, right? Well, maybe
or maybe not. There is now a concerted propaganda,
disinformation effort to claim that the death
toll is being exaggerated. How could that
possibly be? Well, they say and I'll show
you exactly who they are in a moment. They
say that people are actually dying of other
stuff, but doctors are lying and saying it
was coronavirus. There is a sort of spectrum
of the level of crazy that different people
are presenting with this, but that's the general
idea. Let's look at some examples. Here are
diamond and silk. Trump loves these two ladies.
Very, very dangerous propagandists. Take a
look.
In a matter of two weeks, over a thousand
people supposedly died from Corona, from the
Corona virus. And two weeks time period, over
a thousand people after being tested positive,
have died from the Corona virus. But it took
39 days from January all the way up to February.
The twenty ninth, I believe, was the first
person to die.
Here's another thing. Come on. Here's another
thing my president said on March the 24th
Tuesday. This past week, my president said
that he would laugh, come America to be back
up and run.
I knew this was gonna happen. Yeah, I said.
He said this was gonna happen. Go ahead. At
the time he said.
There was twenty five thousand four hundred
and eighty nine cases with three hundred and
seven deaths instantaneously.
You had the media calling President Trump
out who want to open back east. Hey, well,
this open by Easter me. You were talking,
I said. Now watch the numbers of deaths go
up. Right. Watch everything increase because
they wanted to make it. Want to make it look
bad. That's why. Front of our eyes.
They want to make it look bad. So they are
faking the death numbers. Imagine their disbelief.
How did a thousand people die? Well, it's
3000. It's 4000. It's called a virus. It grows
virally. Going viral comes from this from
how quickly it accelerates. That is the whole
origin of the term. This act, by the way,
this counts what I just played for you. That
counts as political analysis to some people
on the right. Donald Trump himself, Don Junior.
They love diamond and silk. They think that
they're brilliant. And this is, of course,
so disrespectful and disgusting to the families
of the thousands of people who have died here
in the United States. Now, here's another
example. This is right wing radio host Mark
Levin, a very well-known bomb thrower, saying
essentially the same thing. I mean, questioning
that the death toll is really accurate.
When you look at the mortality rate that they
say is a direct result of this virus. They
say. Then you see the percentage of people
who die from the virus going down. Going down,
as you might imagine, we've talked about this
last week, plus I cannot find anywhere. The
definition of what it means to die from this
virus. In other words, if I go into the hospital
and I already have a very, very bad heart.
And I'm not given a whole lot of time. Then
I get this virus and it puts me over the edge.
Is I Canada's dying from heart failure, heart
disease, a heart attack? If you have one where
the virus. I don't know. I don't know.
Mark Levine is acting like this is something
unique to the virus, but it's not. I mean,
this is I'll talk to you in a moment, but
this is this is an issue with the flu. This
is an issue with AIDS. We'll get to that in
a moment. Here's Bill Mitchell, right wing
trampas radio host who tweeted, How many people
are dying from Koven? 19. God only knows,
literally. But the numbers being reported
aren't accurate. So let's talk sense here.
Dr. Anthony Foushee has addressed this issue
in some recent interviews. This is a respiratory
disease. If you die from pneumonia complications
and you tested positive for the virus, that's
a corona virus death. And it should be counted
as such, not for political purposes, but for
tracking purposes, for medical purposes, for
epidemiology purposes. It's pneumonia caused
by corona virus. If you have organ failure
caused by the virus. You died of the virus.
And that's how it should be tracked. So they
are now simply saying now you can't believe
the death toll. It's literal gaslighting.
Now, this is an issue. This was an issue and
still is to some degree with AIDS. This is
an issue of the flu. It's not unique to coronavirus.
There's always this issue of me. Listen, there
is someone literally dying of the flu or are
they dying from pneumonia caused by the flu
or a complication caused by the flu or, you
know, a blood marker insufficiency caused
by it? It's a flu death. And there's always
an issue of whether we're attributing enough
deaths to some of these viruses. Now, let
me take the opportunity to tell you something
else. We probably do have an issue about the
number of deaths that's being reported. But
the issue is not that we are overreporting.
The real issue is we are under reporting because
we know that there are people dying of presumptive
case of coronavirus. Not all presumptive cases
are being counted. Sometimes people don't
get tested. You can test them postmortem to
find out if they have the virus. But often
it's not being done because the bodies are
literally piling up in tragic dystopian fashion.
Those should be counted as coronavirus deaths.
Many of them are not. So if the death toll
can't be trusted, it's because it's too low.
Not because it's too high. Don't fall for
it. Don't let them propagate
this nonsense.